your next job is one LinkedIn post away  we're in 2023 now New Year's resolution  if you're sitting and watching this  right now and you hate your [ __ ] job  and you follow what we're seeing which  is tons of people are anxious because a  lot of people are going to lose their  jobs in 2023 please get on the offense  now if you're concerned about your job  or you dislike your job and start making  LinkedIn content share your best  thoughts your observations your hot  takes don't try to go viral don't try to  make what will work make videos write  sentences and paragraphs around  observations insights thoughts you have  for your industry do that LinkedIn posts  every day please start doing that it  will help you it's the unlock